it's a funny thing that that reloading
reloading your your your savegame is
somehow going back in time and changing
things what will change in the present
based on what I do here tonight we have
to design something that works only for
one level so that's not something you do
development usually you you try to
design thing that and make them work for
the entire game so the fact that that
the team went along with that was really
cool and in a happy that this level is
getting this attention it's really cool
if you've played Dishonored 2 or seen
our video review you'll know that a
crack in the slab is an ambitious
mission that allows players to time
travel at the pull of a trigger you use
this power for one mission but once it's
finished you can't use it again from a
development standpoint that makes a
crack in the slab highly unusual making
games particularly modern triple-a games
is very expensive to keep costs down
developers need to maximize what they
get out of the things that they create
so making a complex gameplay mechanic
like time travel for use in just one
level is pretty rare another recent
notable example would be the effect and
cause mission in titanfall 2 which is
also built around time travel I wanted
to learn more about the development of a
crack in the slab where the idea came
from how arcane managed to make two
entirely different versions of the same
area coexist and the challenges it faced
in executing this to do so I Skyped with
Arkane studios christophe carrier to
talk about the making of Dishonored
two's most memorable mission
the story of a crack in the slab began
in 2009 when 2k Marin announced that
arcane would be assisting them with the
design animation and art on Bioshock 2
it's on this project that the seed for a
crack in the slab was planted in
particular a scripted event where
protagonist subject Delta goes back in
time the time I remember I thought wow
that that is awesome that could be
awesome in the paper control that if you
could have some some device or something
that could allow him to to because you
know to go back in time whenever you
wanted and it was you know it triggers a
lot of reflections of what he could do
in the past to change the presence at
the beginning of dishonored to Empress
emily kaldwin is violently deposed by
Delilah copper spoon who was trapped in
the neverending realm of the void until
her unexpected reappearance arcane
needed a way to reveal to play as how
Delilah managed to come back from her
prison and staged her coup and then when
we had this situation where we mind the
player to see the ceremony I thought wow
that's that's the perfect that's the
perfect mechanism to do this and I will
only knew how to do it because we
already did it for Bioshock it except
that it was scripted and not whenever
you wanted but technically it was
feasible
mine Baron Aramis stilton's Grand Manor
is falling to pieces the garden is
overgrown walls of collapsed and dust
has collected inside its great rooms but
with one use of the outsiders timepiece
the player is transported three years
into the past when the Regal mansion is
pristine and beautiful use the timepiece
again and it's ruined once more to
create this illusion arcane had to build
multiple iterations of the mansion that
exists separately from each other
however to establish continuity between
them the player's actions in any of them
had to be reflected in all of them as
you know you change one particular thing
in the level or moving spot here but
then you end up with another level so
this there are basically three levels in
the map and I don't know hi Ron
you have one level and you have another
one below it and then when you activate
the device which at the beginning was
just a dirty pack from us and beside
originally you had a almost a console
comment where you would enter a comment
and then it was teleporting you you know
like 1,000 units below but it was easy
to do because the the mechanism is not
complicated it's just that you have set
the position of the player and of course
we had after that we had to take care of
one of the player teleports in something
that exists in one level but doesn't the
other one so at the beginning if we were
30 14 inside matrix which was bad so
what we have to find ways not to do it
but this came later which is where the
outside is time peace comes in this fan
like item serves as a window into the
past or the future while held in Emily
or corvo's hand players can peek through
its glass like blades to see their
surroundings in the other version of the
mansion this effectively mitigated the
chances of teleporting into a group of
enemies and also introduced an
additional layer of strategy to the
gameplay well personal in level design
that
where you don't want to break the movie
the brain you don't want to bring up on
a platform where there might be guards
we try to avoid this kind of situation
where you don't see the guards that are
up when you try to break somewhere
that's one of the movie try to reinforce
this is actually the same thing with the
time travel you don't want to travel
without seeing you could go as well
travel in the middle of a five guards no
it would be very frustrating and it will
teach you the point of sale and so it
was really important that the villain
you see we're where we are still
affording the timepiece really comes
into its own during a puzzle where you
need to input the code to enter Stilton
study complicating this is a group of
guards patrolling the hallways so
players must avoid guards by shifting
between timelines while quickly entering
the code this would be near impossible
and incredibly frustrating without the
timepieces help these cause-and-effect
puzzles were making changes to the past
allows the player to overcome obstacles
in the future prove to be the most
challenging aspect of the level to
design puzzles are very hard to do
because if you make them too simple
everybody will say is too simple and I
you know that's not a puzzle that's
below me and usually you know the buzzer
are difficult then people will get
restrain it and they get you're going to
go online to find a solution which we
don't on that so we have to balance the
difficulty of the puzzle so that it's
just as difficult enough so that you
know you see what I mean it's like very
apparent that is there is really time
unless you're doing and no powers run by
the time you reach a crack in this lab
you should have accrued a number of
abilities to use however once you step
into stilton's ruined manner you find
your powers drained due to the lasting
effects of Delilah's ritual arcane had
to tow a delicate line make good use of
their new mechanic but without
diminishing the players now power free
Ariane's the first idea was that you
remove some of the powers the mode you
know and we were thinking about just
reading the farm each other blaming
select me because we were afraid that
the player tell you you remove the
mobility power from the from the player
it's it could be curtain you know it
could be annoying or frustrating or
repair might not like that but at the
end of the day we you know the more
we're trying it the just this specific
gameplay of jumping back in time and we
realize that it was cool in itself and
we didn't want and we didn't need to to
add any any power despite restricting
otherworldly abilities like hypnotized
possession and wind blast arcane opted
to keep passive abilities active
removing passives like agility which
allows Emily or Corvo to move faster
would have felt too disempowering to the
player who'd spent the game adapting
their play style to the powers that they
had whereas with an active power is
different they know they can't use in
and it's clearer I don't know if you see
what I mean like it's like certainly you
tell people they can run they will feel
very frustrated
tell them they can try different because
they don't climb often and they know
that in particular situations anyways it
was too punishing for the player to
remove the act the passive powers the
and so we kept on double jump or for a
spell but we moved all the other power
dishonored is about player choice a game
where you want your actions to have
noticeable consequences originally
arcane had big ideas for how player
choice in a crack in the slab would
impact the overall world state but
allowing these ramifications to extend
beyond a single isolated mission could
have created paradoxes that boggle the
mind and may have broken the game
I mean the movie that I prefer is the
one where something you changed
something in the past and then the
present is different because of
direction you know in arcane we love
when when there are consequences to what
you do so it's perfect because you do
something and you see consequences the
thing is at the beginning we wanted to
go real far with the concept like for
example knowing that the entire dusty
street would be different when you come
back right there's no power laszlo
overseers as the war you know is to
faction finally show them to be not be
here and you could explore levels and
the bar where Paulo is would be a normal
bar with people and then the mining a
building where when the overseers I put
their HQ would have been the regular
mining but it was too much horse and and
this would happen only for a tiny
fraction a player would have done the
thing that that courage I told you
before what we're saying so yeah at the
beginning it was wanted to do something
really big and of course we could not do
this it was great crazy we try to
contain the changes so that there were
not crazy in term of production so we
did things that are a bit Eden but not
too much and most of the first went into
the puzzles that you have to do solve to
progress
what I was doing and dunwall on this
night or what I am doing thanks for
watching this insider's look at the
creation of certainly my favorite
dishonor to level for more deep dive
videos like this one make sure to check
out GameSpot studio's latest series a
look at the rise fall and future of
Resident Evil for more videos just like
this one make sure to LIKE and subscribe
to GameSpot and we'll see you next time
[Music]